Google Cloud updates immersive stream
for XR leverages Google Cloud gpus to
host render and stream high quality
photorealistic experiences to millions
of mobile devices around the world
without even downloading an app and the
best part it's generally available check
out the post for more details including
some really cool customer examples
running sap workloads on Google Cloud
upgrade to our newly released agent for
sap for increased visibility into your
infrastructure and app performance
consolidating many of our existing
agents for sap workload this means less
time updating and installing and more
time making data-driven decisions check
out our recent white paper three actions
that Enterprise it leaders can take to
improve software supply chain security
and learn how and why high profile
software supply chain attacks have
happened and which key lessons and
actions you can take to protect your
organization get more on all stories at
the links below thanks for watching